welcome to this video playing G Rome
what does do run play Bishop c4 okay so
at least not the Italian Knight takes e4
is possible not that interesting I think
the Queen age five this adds a soft spot
in my repertoire is it no no you can
take it what kind of is that I'm getting
crazier really really so let's take it
don't believe the stuff and what now
never shop c 5 will check so what's
going on here if he cancels i mean if i
go afore the screen give five
I know not g5 actually what what was I
thinking I cannot kikuchi seven ah come
on this is sick against such a crap
opening I can't just take on f4 whatever
I never born up I was thinking ah I was
just thinking 25 Queenie 7 yeah when
they can do this first of course and now
this f7 is bloody hanging and this is
this [ __ ] is actually now justified
oh my god
now whatever this is losing hey just
take care for I mean this is complete
nonsense this opening okay so yeah 96
win some material it's okay this is
probably the rather minor sorrow him
minor concern
calm so okay um so we just see want to
go you want to go to f7 again probably
can anyway I can take you can take this
of course I mean okay just it just too
bad it's just too bad
you can go Bishop d3 this is a yachting
move I wish the singing Bishop takes
fish 94 of it okay he just goes to d3 of
course mmhmm yeah okay doesn't matter
I'm just continuing because I he might
just I don't know do something really
stupid but it's very unlikely
yeah it is the right thing you just
develop yeah I mean I'm totally on the
ropes and now it's check on the seven
this is why you did it okay but if I
take me for am i mated a magic made it
here clap I'm checkmated if i go to BD 8
and here i'm probably also somehow mated
but Bishop c5 you can take this so i
have to go here this is actually a game
again you blunder the piece there for
nothing interesting Bishop 25 or what's
the tli to see 5 or what's the deal
maybe you should see 5a player for
staying on this be three
let's see here I cannot take 10 for
unfortunately might take is seven or
something I don't know what am I playing
in this bloody game I'm just kind of
completely getting insane yeah it seems
or even this I can take you for and what
what I mean ok I understand it's been a
long day but why do I play like I'm
brain dad come on this is crazy he let
me in the game again after this this is
total blunder that I did in the opening
and I'm not taking this opportunity here
clap hi Barney check again but I have to
get out of this first here 95mm check
first I can check here clap and den
bussche young age 3 threatening made
threatening check mate check
yeah this year's I made a spoon track
wow I completely swindle turn white
resigns oh my god that was the worst
game ever oh my god ready ok well the
opening is this really this is just
[ __ ] right I think if I take a I
must be fine so here here here now I
mean that that simply cannot work I
don't believe it i mean if i just take i
should be fine I mean really he's got a
he's a pawn down for what here if he
cancels I check him and cancel myself so
so this and then the check you can I
should be too that's very little
compensation I mean I can probably
cancel long but it's got some decent
development he forced like I mean I saw
this line it's not like I didn't see
anything I thought this but here I'm of
course just completely dead trap
completely dad player d5 oops yeah
whatever i mean- a million and then he
blundered listen in a move hair cut and
still worse but somehow the game is
continuing I looked you six this is a
hiss acute move oh my god this game is
the worst ever I could have taken the
bishop and Mike
this is bizarre I swear I'm not drunk I
just haven't just had a very long day
incredible incredible route d6 again
wins I mean and now I'd blundered this
and now it's scary kind of interesting
again in the position yeah this was this
is probably killing right yeah rookie to
is the only thing that kind of
continuous and he it's already a force
mate it cannot prevent the main ja yeah
and here this is a tomato chopped hope
that that's very terrible what a
terrible game I forgot to switch on the
analysis actually yeah I mean I saw you
saw the blunders I mean I'm just
completely stunned anyway thanks for
watching